elizabeth ostrander spent the majority
of the pandemic two years waiting for a
lung transplant i was getting a little
bit frustrated and
just
depressed about you know
not getting the match the weight is
excruciating and can be extended for
those with certain blood types if i have
someone that is very sick and for
example is an old blood type
and i get a
b or a donor offer
for transplantation i cannot transplant
that patient dr marcelo saipel and his
team are trying to level the playing
field in a new experiment the first of
its kind they say they've converted
donor lungs with one blood type to a
universal type
then patient in need of a organ
transplant
would have access
to
all the organs regardless of their blood
type blood type is determined by the
presence of antigens on the surface of
the red blood cells in our bodies type a
has the a antigen b has b
a b has both a and b
and type o the universal blood type has
none
saipel needed to clear any antigens from
the organs and stephen withers at the
university of british columbia had the
perfect enzyme the enzymes themselves
are ones that we discovered by hunting
within the human gut microbiome which in
reality means in human theses those
enzymes were injected into one lung from
a type a donor the other was left
untreated researchers then introduced
type o blood to both simulating what
would happen when an organ is
transplanted into a patient
and what we could see is that these
lungs did not present any signs
of rejection clinical trials are next
elizabeth who finally got her lung by
the way is hopeful
there'd be more transplants more organs
available potentially breathing new life
experts say into an unfair and outdated
system jamie morocco global news toronto